we come in with nothing and we're going
to come out with nothing our short life
here on Earth is just a glimpse hi just
listen to Samuel lead's presentation
been fantastic five key point to to
success Financial Freedom you need to
get his V bless you see you soon let's
give our the men's room appreciation
Men's Room
appreciation
to
some appreciate
the second time we've had Samuel speak
at one of our conferences he was
excellent last time and he was excellent
this time bring him along because he's
got great knowledge um and he presents
in a really humorous way our guys were
really engaged this is probably the best
presentation I've ever
[Music]
heard